this morning we have the privilege
of the first lecture of robert moore
for us in this conference
robert moore is a union analyst
he is a training analyst at the cg young
institute in chicago
he is also professor of psychology and
religion
at chicago theological seminary
he's the editor of carl jung and
christian spirituality
which is a book that you will find over
here on the table
there are six more volumes
already under contract of this series
that book is a
series and there are six others on the
contract
which will examine the relationship of
carl jung
to other major religions of the world
he's the president of the institute for
world spirituality as well and
and also is the co-editor of jung's
challenge to contemporary religion
robert was a lecturer for us a few years
ago
and he spoke then on the masculine
archetypes in a very powerful way
at that particular time we were into a
lot of the
feminine archetypes and uh
the feminine involvement and there were
a lot of men that said
we need some masculine input
and so we called upon robert and it was
a powerful series and i know what he has
to offer
for us now will also be a powerful time
and experience
thank you jim it's a pleasure for me to
be
here with journey into wholeness again
it's an honor for me to be
part of the advisory board i really
believe in the work
that jim and annette and all of you are
doing i think it's one of the most
important
institutions of the
provision of a forum for for the
discussion of the important
relationships between jungian thought in
general and
christian spirituality in in particular
as well as the uh widespread struggle to
formulate a human spirituality which is
equal to a uh postmodern planetary
culture
and this is a enormously important thing
and
it's it's a joy to be with all of you
and john dowerly uh last evening was
emphasizing a lot of uh the contribution
as he used it of
of jung's theological ideas
i'm going to emphasize this morning
especially and in my second lecture
the psychology
itself the the uniqueness of young
psychology and why it is we turn to
young psychology
particularly and not just others
and so i want to say a little bit about
uh the uniqueness of young psychology
for those of you who are not schooled in
comparative psychology or comparative uh
psychoanalytic theory uh i'm privileged
to have the responsibility of teaching
comparative
psychoanalytic theory at the doctoral
level
as some of you know before i was a
jungian psychoanalyst i was an adlerian
psychoanalyst
and before i wrote anything on young i
wrote my first book was a freudian book
so i have sort of uh recapitulated
the history of the psychoanalytic
movement in my long journey
my niece once asked me why i went to
school so long and i said honey some of
us just take longer than others to get
around to
the right things but let me just say
just a word
it seems to me that the genius of young
psychology which we
uh who are our theorists
and practitioners of his psychology have
to constantly keep in mind
is his understanding that the
unconscious
is structured now this
this is an incredibly important idea
and let me just say why because it's the
only
school of psychoanalytic theory
that views the unconscious as
a place that can actually be mapped
it is related to chomsky's model of
linguistics
that there are in fact deep structures
in the human psyche
in the unconscious that the unconscious
is not just
like audience used to teach uh
a cauldron of energy that is basically
chaotic
the unconscious is full of deep
structures
which influence and in too many ways
determine the life of the ego
and so if you think a moment about that
if if jung is right
as i believe he is it means
that serious careful study can help open
up a geography of the inner world
so that you will not be totally lost
when you start
exploring the psyche and psychic life
that is there are predictable things
that you can recognize
in the inner world and this is not
uh something which is just somebody's
conceptual idea these are things which
jung viewed as being something we find
empirically
through research this is a
phenomenological investigation
these are not somebody's uh strange
mystical religious ideas
these are structures in the psyche which
can be seen whether you're a union or
not
if you can look carefully enough and so
what i want to emphasize this morning is
is young
psychology as a scientific empirical
psychology
of the deep structures of the human
unconscious
the way to talk about this is the
archetypes are not jungian
they are human jung simply
was a pioneer in map beginning
to map them and there have been others
that have done this now what i want
i'll get to end now get into showing you
why that is
important in the context of our
conference and our topic
the first thing i'd like to do a number
of things i've got too much here
to do and we'll see how far we get this
morning and i'll pick up
if i don't get as far as i want to get
i'll pick up in the second
presentation tomorrow but but here's the
way i want to proceed first i want to
give you a quick geography
of the different spaces in the
unconscious and the objective psyche
particularly located in what we call the
the archetypal self or the conyotio
then i want to show you where i in terms
of my research
locate the psychology of satan
there is a particular location in the
archetypal structures in the psyche
where you can see the human
preoccupation with evil
and then i will move into elaborating
that in terms of what has been called
the combat myth
because the struggle between good and
evil has always in human culture been
been talked about in terms of the combat
myth and i want to show you the the
salient aspects of the combat myth
and then i want to show you some
different
psychoanalytic perspectives on what may
be
going on in this combat myth what is
this that is being combated in other
words we need this morning to reflect
upon the psychological understanding of
what we would call evil
and we throw around the word evil a lot
and we tend to get too much into these
meta meta meta meta discussions
about uh the provocative bony and all
these things
but i'm a clinician primarily uh and not
a meta meta meta theoretician primarily
and so i want to show you uh uh in today
and
and tomorrow the concrete clinical
experiential
uh things in psychopathology that you
can recognize as being manifestations of
the psychology of evil
now during the course of our discussions
we will have an opportunity for you to
think and do your spiritual theology
because you're all going to have to do
your own theology of this stuff
because because it admits of different
interpretations and so one of the last
things i'll try to get to today
is showing you what paul recur the great
philosopher would call the the conflict
of interpretations
on this there are many ways to draw
uh conclusions about uh the
way in which evil is structured
psychologically and the meaning of that
theologically
so we'll see i'm just going to present
to you some of the options i i will tell
you what seems to make more sense to me
but uh i can't play uh
the vatican here for you so you're going
to have to you're going to have to do
your own theology and struggle with that
this week
so if you're ready uh feel free to raise
your hand
during my presentation i'm going to go
awfully fast the material this morning
is about eight hours of material i'm
gonna i'm gonna hit the ground running
i've got to be able to see it too
the uh this first business
is is a business this is this is
research in price
process now and
it's going to take a long time to
develop this adequately
but i i'm known more
for my work on the psychoanalysis of
space
and ritual around the world i i'm known
widely in terms of being a specialist in
in the study of psychoanalysis and
ritual and particularly ritual spaces
i have continued that work and uh i have
come to
work on a kind of a structural analysis
which
which uh is grounded in young's fault
but carries it forward empirically
uh in terms of the different spaces in
the psyche
uh in terms of the different ways in
which the
uh you you have studied some alchemy and
you know that jung talked a lot about
the
uh uh the mysterium kenyans
the uh the king and queen within uh and
that many jungians believe that is the
most adequate
representation of the archetypal self
that the archetypal self
uh people talk about it being
represented clearly with christ but
actually the most adequate in terms of
jungian psychoanalysis
the most adequate representation of the
archetypal self is really
is really the rex and regina the the
king and queen
of the alchemical couple and uh this
you see this clearly in terms of the
fact that we are all
uh containing we all contain both sexes
in the deep structures of our psyche and
but what i have found in my work is that
this
this archetypal couple uh when you look
empirically at individuals you
find them you find that they manifest
themselves in very
discreet ways in different people and
and while you can say that the that the
center of the psyche is expressed and
imaged
best in terms of the king and queen
you also find a warrior couple within
you also find a priest and priestess
within
or the magician couple you also find
a pair of lovers within
if i had time i would go into a lot of
the mythology which elaborates this
now in terms of world mythology the king
and queen
take on these different personas at
different times in their life
if they're making love they're
manifesting in this form
aphrodite in eros see
if they are manifesting as the great
uh magician you may have seen martin
smith's book
jesus the magician well then they are in
this form if they're the
priest and priestess of magic they're
represented here
if they are if they are on the war path
uh we see there's a lot in marriages
here
i'm not kidding you i will get into that
because
because if you if you are in the warrior
space and you're trying to deal with
your spouse
and your spouse doesn't understand this
deep structural psychological stuff
that spouse may get into the warrior
space with you
and if you don't understand that your
job together is to fight chaos
and not each other you're going to have
problems
uh but anyway so so so the
king and queen manifest this way and
then they manifest uh
in terms of their role as the center of
the world
and so you have four different
manifestations
in the tio and the only way to really
get a sense for this is to study world
mythology about the gods and goddesses
and you will see when you study the gods
and goddesses you start with gene
bolen's work on this
gods and every woman goddesses and every
woman gods and every man so forth
and you can see in the variety of the
expressions of the gods in mythology
different ways in which different times
in which they manifest in these
different ways
but it's all the uh
in terms of a psychoanalytic viewpoint
it's all various manifestations of the
great man
and the great woman within which is the
archetypal self
now that's a whole thing in itself yes
oh yes i'm gonna do that right now uh
the four different spaces that are
created this is the interesting thing
that and i'm teaching courses now on on
the relationship of this to couple
therapy
because because they're they're distinct
psychosocial
spaces spaces that exist in each of
these with each of these couples as they
manifest in
in the psyche if a husband or a
wife is in the king and queen
uh on the throne kind of space
they will be almost all parents
they will be invested in creating a
cosmos or world this is cosmos in the
technical sense that iliadi uses it
this is a ordered justly ordered
world and
there's no sexuality to speak out here
you wouldn't even know that the king and
queen had genitals
in this in this modality and when a
husband and wife get into this
their sex life goes to hell
you see if they're locked into this
now so the space that emerges
from the king and queen is this this
world building or we'd say family
building
home building nest making
you know business building you know so
forth
church building
but anyway it's a very special kind of
space with very special kind of concerns
and it excludes
the others if you want to know why some
clergy are not
interested in spiritual direction ask
yourself well are they locked into the
king stuff or the queen stuff
because if they're into the king being
the king or queen
they're not they're probably not
interested in the spiritual direction
stuff
which is here see
okay you follow that okay so the space
the space of spiritual direction is here
the
spiritual direction and liturgical
leadership in which is serious liturgy
serious ritual
serious attempts at transformation is
liminal space liminality
sacred space transformative space
that is the space that opens up when the
psyche the great south
is manifest in this form this is what
the psychoanalyst
has to get into but
must get into it consciously
um gene and wallace cliff were
were talking the other night about about
how easy it is for psychoanalysts to
to become inflated in an identification
with the great magician
and priest and spiritual directors and
clergy do that too see
so uh so you've got to realize this is a
part of the great self and you you need
to
utilize it but not identify with it
that's the principle we'll be operating
on today
so down here this is the garden space
this is the eden
the space of passion it's either it's
the it is the garden of delight
and it is the garden of sorrow when this
is the space
of intense
love and vulnerability
see if you love i guarantee you
you will suffer see
they don't they don't come separately
if you love you will suffer in and that
is the space of the lover
and uh it has a specific purpose in the
psyche of making you human
see that's his purpose making you feel
but
if you don't love you're not vulnerable
see if you're not vulnerable you're not
human
see of course you can get in trouble
with this and you can spend a little
time thinking well how do you get in
trouble with this well you get in
trouble with this when you identify with
a great magician
a man gets in trouble with this when he
when he identifies with great phallus
see i'm serious
uh and the woman with a great yoni
so many men so little time
okay now i wish i had more time we'd go
into that more
but
[Music]
but that's not our purpose this morning
i'm trying to locate
the struggle with evil in the psyche
archetypally now that's where we come
here
it is in the warrior space that the
archetypal structures in terms of the
the archetypal combat with evil is it
fits
and the space here
right right uh here jihad
it's the muslim idea of spiritual
warfare
spiritual struggle that's what jihad
means to the muslims
to the muslim particularly if you want
to understand the shiites
they're mainlining they're shooting up
this archetypal structure
their their spirituality is is centered
right here
service to allah is struggle and if
you're not
struggling in the spiritual warfare you
are
not a muslim and
so that is where this is located see and
this in christian mythology excuse me
liberation theology is locked right
there uh
armageddon the the apocalyptic fantasies
of the religious right
are locked right here and so
so there is this struggle now notice
this this could
when you don't when you don't know about
this stuff you can be husband and wife
here and then you can have always
armageddon between you
and you know there used to be a lot of
so-called marital therapists
that would play lest you and him fight
you two are not what's wrong with you is
you two are not fighting enough
you know they ought to be sued for
malpractice
my view because if a couple is locked
into this
more fighting doesn't help all you get
is agatha damarang
where the where the god and the goddess
make
[Music]
magnificent majestic warfare
you know like uh world war two
battleships with their 16-inch guns
going this way see
but anyway the important thing to
realize is that
this is the space of combat with evil
in the psyche yes
well you gotta help them understand that
that uh
their warrior self is real fine and
dandy and good but it exists to destroy
and uh and if they have to learn to
participate in some of these other
spaces
and what i do in my couple work my work
with couples is i
immediately come here and i says hey you
two
we need to help you find the garden
because you have lost it
and you show me a couple with a lot of
marital problems i'll show you a couple
that has lost the garden
yes the film that shows magnificent
warfare between the
you know the king and the queen i never
see anything like it is dangerous
liaison
yes it's phenomenal yeah yeah well that
thing is that that's got a lot of
wonderful archetypal uh modes but now we
gotta move on
remember where we are here i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna deepen this now we've
got to get into this space more deeply
you ready you're located here
okay here we go stay there because this
is an elaboration of that space
this is the combat myth let me give you
a reference for you that uh
that love getting into serious
mythological and historical research
there's a new book out with princeton
university press
by a man the name of forsythe
f-o-r-s-y-t-a
it's called the old enemy
and it is a comparative study of the
combat myth
now remember we're dealing with this not
from historical critical work
in mythology we're dealing with in terms
of the psychology of the archetypes
but what this man has done is in my view
provided you with a wonderful study
of the archetype of the sacred combat
here it is right here they just happen
to have some copies of this
it's also very cheap isn't it sid i
think
it's uh it doesn't say they didn't put
the price in for you okay
it's only about
67.50 but it's worth it
if you really want to understand the
archetypal uh dynamics behind the human
struggle about evil
it's the best thing i've ever seen and
what we will do in just a minute is to
go through some of this but anyway
you've got to get a sense that in the
psyche
the warrior aspect of of the psyche
when it is functioning correctly
serves the king and the queen
there's your knighthood ideal
now what is the nature of the service
it is to defend cosmos
just order a a moral order
against the forces of chaos
that is what is for the warrior in the
psyche
archetypally in every culture
is to defend the just order
the moral order against the forces
of chaos now you can see this a lot of
ways archetypally and if you study
mandalas
what a mandala is is an image of cosmos
and at the center archetypally is
the two thrones of the conyotio
now in patriarchal cultures there's one
throne
and in matriarchal cultures there's one
throne
in the human psyche there are two
thrones
and in the more primitive mythologies
that you study
you see two thrones in other words in
the deeper structures of the psyche
expressions in myth you will always see
two thrones not one
uh you can see it in the ancient
egyptian mythology and you see it in a
lot of the
the extremely old mythologies they have
different they have different wraps on
that but if you understand this stuff
psychodynamically you can see that this
is the throne of the conjunction
see the two thrones but it's always
identified with
a lot of archetypal imagery you've got
to study your iliadi to understand this
the oxus mundi the center of the world
the sacred tree who is the sacred tree
it's either the king or the queen or
both always
the cross of christ of course is
the sacred tree at the center of the
cosmos
you must find the center of the axis
mundia the cosmos or there will be chaos
evil will triumph see
okay so in the spatial
portraits of the world that you see in
the ancient world
it is always mandalic always
and if you study ancient cities
cities are images of cosmos
polish is cosmos
in microcosm so if you study
memphis in ancient egypt
or not not tennessee
that's right you study you study that's
right but but if you the
some of the most interesting studies
today are in geography
sacred geography in geography
departments and our
studies in architecture and geography
departments where they're studying
uh the archetypal images of the city
because they're grounded right here on
this for our purposes
we have to see that the thing which
impinges
and threatens always is chaos from the
outside of the cosmos
and you could even envision this as a
sphere
and chaos comes from all directions
and it is the king and queen in their in
their
incarnation as warlords
when they get up and go to defend the
world
against the forces of chaos now
in human history that gets divided into
social roles and you get the knights
who defend the king and the queen
but in fact they are expressing an
aspect
of the great general himself or herself
the warlord who carries the fight to
chaos
in other words the king doesn't always
sit on the throne
sometimes they get up and button up with
their armor and pick up the sword
now you can see what my favorite image
of the queen in her in her warlord
garb is aliens too sigourney weaver my
heroine
and and if you haven't seen aliens too
you've got to see aliens too because
that is an image i tell my female
theologian friends if you want to see an
image
of the god liberator in female form
sigourney weaver and aliens too if you
haven't seen it you gotta check that out
i always try to sell vcr as i get a
commission
now the combat myth is often portrayed
like this and
but you need to realize that these are
the same images just presented
differently
remember that
the god king queen always
they are the center
and so wherever they are they are the
center so when you're representing this
spatially
uh you've got a problem but you need to
recognize that this
and this is really describing the same
space
but here our experience in the psyche
our experience
of the enemy if you've seen sam king's
book faces of the enemy
we experience the enemy out there
in fact the less developed we are in
terms of psychodynamics
that's where we experience the enemy
first
uh the more developed we are spiritually
and this is true of every human
spiritual tradition of any death
the first place you encounter the enemy
is within
and only then do you turn to
encountering the enemy without
this is true in the martial arts
in the oriental martial arts as well as
a lot of our own spiritual traditions
but let me just run through this could
somebody get me a little water i'm gonna
run out of voice if we don't
give me some water this again here is
the plane you can see the plane of
struggle
and in this old enemy book you get a
comparative charting
of the different expressions that this
is taken in human culture and if you
look at that and you don't believe in
the archetypes then i can't help you
here we've got i'll just go through
these i hope you can hear me
you've read beowulf
beowulf who is the archetypal
christian king
grindel the dragon see
and they're struggling in the
patriarchal myths
marduk fighting
the great dragon of chaos tiamat now
this is uh
what i consider a patriarchal fantasy
you know
men love to dismember feminine
grandiosity
and women love to dismember masculine
grandiosity
the hard thing is for men to dismember
masculine grandiosity and for women to
dismember
feminine grandiosity we'll get more to
that a little bit but anyway in
patriarchal myths
the the masculine hero takes on the
giant forces feminine forces of chaos
so there's an image of evil in
zoroastrianism
you get ahura mazda
the lord of light fighting ahiraman
the lord of darkness
in jewish tradition
uh there are a lot of really excellent
studies coming out now about
yahweh as warrior
in fact being a good southerner i kind
of appreciate this
there are some scholars that think that
yahweh is what the
hebrews shouted when they attacked
and that's kind of like a rebel yell
yahoo
that's serious bible scholars honestly
they they've begun to think that yahweh
was a battle cry
and it was an invocation of the war god
so they would win
and uh so when the when yahweh is
attacking the forces of baal
male represents
this is the chaos lord
in indonesian mythology i was privileged
to travel extensively in indonesia
recently
form of hinduism the great epic ramayana
in the ramayana it's the great lord rama
that's a hindu christ figure
and who he is in struggle with is
rahwana
i started to bring my great wanna mask
i thought i better wait until i practice
with that thing a little bit more so we
don't get anybody possessed during these
conferences
but i mean it's a great demon face you
know
but rajuana is the great lord of evil
the great lord of chaos and rama the
whole ramayana is the story and in
indonesia this myth is alive this is a
lo that if you you know you don't go to
the movies so much in indonesia
as you go to the dances in the center of
the towns
and the all people of all ages come out
and and everybody has tried out to be
the different parts in this epic
and they present on the stage the
ramiana and everywhere you look it's the
ramayana
and they dance this myth and it's alive
for them and on their ancient temples
this is
the myth it's on their temples you can
study hinduism in america and never even
learn about this
you can well hinduism is this that and
the other but in indonesia
hinduism is the ramayana
and of course in our myth you get the
christ
satan conflict uh
in revelations yes of god antichrist
exactly now see what i'm trying to get
you to see
we're just doing psychology now this is
just archetypal psychology this is in
your wiring
and this is not in your software
see this is in the main drive
and what you've got to realize is all
these real sweet nice
folks you know that are going to do away
with war
i i hate to tell them
but warfare is built in to the hard
drive
so in my view and this is what i think
you as christians need to think about
in my view the question is not whether
we're going to do away with warfare or
not the question is whether we're going
to engage in the real war or not
human beings love to make war especially
men i i agree with the feminists here
while there is a female warrior in the
hard drive
of a woman you see it in sigourney
weaver
while there's a hard drive while she's
in the hard drive
that doesn't get as much electricity in
the typical woman most of the time
unless she has to
turn those circuits on men
are wired for that constantly and if you
watch little masculine games we call
them blank contests
think about that
uh but anyway they're little war games
war games are masculine games and
the the the tragic thing if in one view
uh if if the psyche in its instinctual
form is tragic
and i guess in some ways you might say
that uh but that's not gonna change
well in my view what you've got to do is
to
understand what the real enemy is and
that's what our job this morning is
psychologically and you can do your own
theology of it psychodynamically
speaking
uh i want to get now to
what the real enemy is psychologically
and you can see this
in studying human mythology as well as
in studying comparative psychoanalytic
theory
what is the enemy within
now i want to address just briefly
scott peck's book people of a lie
uh his road less traveled is a fine book
people of the lie
is a dangerous book and a and a
very very misleading book
even at the time that tech understands a
lot of important points about this
where i can say that i want to suggest
that you
look at textbook so you'll know it's
good points and bad points
he identifies the psychodynamics of evil
as lying in in pathological narcissism
i want to suggest to you that rightly
understood
that is correct psychologically speaking
the enemy within that is what human
beings have known as the evil
that afflicts the human race wherever
it's found is pathological narcissism
and i'll get into that more in a minute
the danger about peck
is that he assigns a certain very few
people
with that category of being evil
personalities
obviously peck is not very familiar with
the psychoanalytic literature
if he were very familiar with the
psychoanalytic literature
he would understand that all of the
psychopathological
uh syndromes manifest narcissistic
pathology
just because you're not a dsm-3 or
dsm-3r narcissistic personality disorder
doesn't mean that you're not a
pathological narcissist
and see if he had studied his
psychoanalytic theory he would know that
the other thing when he describes
meeting people in his practice that are
so evil he can't work with him or he's
paralyzed in their presence
if he had studied enough about counter
transference
he would never written that he would
have talked to his supervisor about it
i'm serious that's embarrassing to see
someone who is so widely touted as a
great psychotherapist who doesn't
understand more about counter
transference than that
now i'm not questioning that a lot of
the people that he may have experienced
as
virulently toxic in terms of
pathological narcissism may not well may
well not have been
tremendously sick narcissist i don't but
but any analyst
that has a practice that doesn't cater
merely to
to well healed neurotics
will see very sick narcissist
and any honest psychoanalyst that's done
enough analysis will know about the
sector in their own personality that is
full eaten up with pathological
narcissism
you show me an analyst who is not aware
of their own residual crazy
cycle almost psychotic
borderline sector in their psyche where
they are more autistic
and incapable of love they just haven't
had enough analysis
because the best work that's been done
on this field shows that
no psychoanalyst ever gets to the bottom
of that finally
and the ones that think they have are
the ones you don't want to go to
but let me just quickly run through
these different
theories
we're doing all right
now let me just give you what i would
define
as the psychological root of human evil
i'm just going to bracket all that
non-human evil
i'll let the theologians that are
interested in
all those niceties of the arguments deal
with that non-human evil earthquakes and
all that stuff
i'm just going to deal with human evil
the fundamental mechanism of human evil
psychologically speaking is pathological
infantile grandiosity
pathological infantile
grandiosity now
the interesting thing is that in the
different schools of psychoanalytic
thought the different major schools they
all have a feeling for this
some that are better and more clearly
than others
but that is to say that that whatever
this is that is
that is behind and fueling compulsive
destructive human acting out in all
sorts of ways and i will get into this
in detail in in the
lecture on discernment and helping us
look for signs of
pathological infantile narcissism in
ourselves because there are ways to
dig that stuff up in your own
self-scrutiny
but for now very simply
there is this sort of uh
two to three year old high chair tyrant
in the psyche and it's really in there
and the interesting thing according to
psychoanalytic theory it's in
everybody and
it is within
and it has certain recognizable
forms it expresses itself in now let's
go back to classical psychoanalytic
theory now
just very briefly notice the
characteristics of the two major
structures that the human ego
has to struggle with in sigmund freud's
early classical psychoanalysis
here you've got the little human ego
embattled on two sides
on the one side the superego or we'd
call it the
conscience some would cause the bad
moral
conscience on the other side the id or
the it
the instinctual the primitive primary
process
instinctual drives what do they have in
common well they make totalistic claims
they make perfectionistic claims they
make
grandiose claims on the ego
what are the grandiose claims of the id
it's very simple according to freud
the id in you wants to eat everything
it can see including you
and it wants to screw everything
male or female
animal vegetable or mineral
and if you study as i have the sexual
so-called perversions you will find that
human beings see
contrary to what we nice folks like to
look at human beings manage
to following the drives of the id to
engage in sexual behavior
with everything and that is the it
acting out it wants to have sex with
everything it's that it's the thing that
fuels that so many men so little time so
many women so little time of the
promiscuous personality
now so and it's also behind uh those of
us that ought to be in
uh overeaters anonymous
we want we want to eat everything you
know i see i see a table of these good
vittles around here and i just want to
pig out see
and it doesn't matter that i don't need
it i i want to eat some more it's so
good
those ribs we had the other night
i won't even talk about wild turkey
now the superego how is it grandiose
well it makes grandiose claims on you to
be perfect
the superego is even brilliant enough to
make grandiose claims about your being
perfect in your sexuality
and there are a lot of folks you know
they've read the joy of sex and
the joy of sex revisited and the joy of
sex three
and the joy of sex for
and every time they make love they think
boy okay
that was about a four
and uh and and they never can just uh
they never can get into the garden
because you know if you're in the garden
you don't count
you know think about that one
you got to think about that
but the super ego is never satisfied
with you and one of the things you need
to know if you're one of these ambitious
professional types you know that's going
to write a lot of books or
make a lot of money or get real
successful in your profession
you know get a big church or whatever it
is what you're going to discover
is that no matter how many books you
write no matter how much money you make
no matter how many homes you own no
matter how many uh
branches of your business you've got
there's going to be a part in your
psyche that's going to say yeah
you're not much
you're really a failure
why don't you take a cocaine overdose
a lot of people in fact the more
creative you are the more that voice
speaks
and the more successful you are
creatively
the more danger you have from that voice
because the more successful you are you
begin to realize my god i'm not ever
going to be able to quiet this voice
that's why so many entertainers commit
suicide that's why so many successful
professionals become drug addicts and
alcoholics
okay so the grandiose self is expressed
in the forms of the super ego and id in
in classical union
i mean freudian theory now look at adler
now a lot of people don't know about
adler and you say adler a lot of people
say power power complex well that's
right but it's so shallow it doesn't
tell you anything about adlerian theory
the genius of adlerian theory is their
intuition
that behind ever inferiority you know
they calling the inferiority complex
everybody knows that word but very few
people know superiority complex
and if you don't know the concept of the
superiority complex you don't understand
the inferiority complex because in
adlarian psychoanalysis
if you have an inferiority complex you
do
have in the unconscious
a superiority complex and all adelarian
psychotherapy is
is the therapist will work with you
trying to find the way in which you
are acting as if you're entitled to a
above human place in life that's all
that larian therapy is
they're going to try to help you rejoin
the human race
get down off of your high chair see
and so the what what is known today in
in avon guard circles as the grandiose
exhibitionist itself organization adler
discovered
years ago they always come up with
adler's ideas
and think they invented them but the
superiority complex is that
great presuming self within which always
beats you down
and always depreciates you and other
people and is never satisfied with you
or other people so there's the infantile
grandiosity and adilarian theory
if i had more time i'd go into it more
but let's go on to the object relations
theorist
there's a lot of work in this field but
they have what is known as the concept
of the anti-libidinal ego
this is a part of your psyche which you
have
within which
once you dead
it does not want you in relationships
that are satisfying
in fact it will try to get you into
relationships with you into it will fail
that thus thus explaining a lot about
the tendency of human beings to do
the same mistake again and again and
again with different people
but anyway the important thing to
realize is that here in this object
relations theory which is a very
influential school of thought now
that there is a thing in the psyche that
is not
the eye
but is a discernible structure which
wants the individual dead
and if you're a practicing therapist you
see this thing acting in people all the
time
because you will notice that about the
time they start making a lot of progress
they will do something to set themselves
back
and when they get involved you know it
may be a person that's managed to always
choose the wrong person to have a
relationship with you know abusive
men or women and then
they will find this absolutely wonderful
praise be god individual that doesn't
abuse them
but it's so fascinating once you find
somebody that won't abuse you you become
bored with them
and start doing things to sabotage the
relationship
fascinating to watch and in working with
individuals you're constantly having to
alert them now
now which part of you is running this
you know what is this part of you that
doesn't want you to be married
behind this they want you to sit in your
room alone and drink
you know and so uh there's a whole
literature on the anti-libido
ego and there's a whole literature and a
different wing of that talking about
toxic introductions that is the parts of
us which modern psychoanalysis
recognizes as
inner entities real inner entities that
are out to kill us
and uh now remember this is not jungian
thought
this is other schools of psychoanalysis
which recognize
these compulsive destructive forces
within the psyche that are out to
destroy the human life of the person
uh usually they are perfectionistic
usually they are rageful and full of
hatred and envy
and we'll get more into the marks of
that stuff tomorrow
but but but these parts of the psyche
usually are full of rage
and they are inconsolable
in other words nothing anybody could
ever do would ever satisfy them
we don't have enough time to get into
melanie klein
but she is another person she's been
she's a freudian but she's been accused
of being a union
because she believes that there are in
fact these
innate drives in the psyche
which fuel hate and envy
and if the end if the person cannot
learn to
cope and counteract these inner enemies
these parts of the psyche
that want to destroy the beloved
and want to destroy the good life
then they will die probably by suicide
maybe by other forms of depression or
compulsive behavior
now the school of thought that i want to
recommend the non-jungian school that's
most interesting and most
easily related to jung is the school of
kohut's self-psychology
heinz a t ati and z cohab kohut
his self psychology in self psychology
they make a very clear statement it's
very interesting
pathological behavior
is the result of an individual's
not being able to cope with the power of
the grandiose self-organization within
now think about this now get this now i
want you to try to get you ready for the
understanding of what the archetypal
self is
and jungian thought yes
yeah yes but what i want you to get
about this
is that we're not talking theology here
we're not talking uh some sort of uh
abstraction
we're talking about clinical phenomena
that atheists
see when they look
at pathological personalities they see
these cohesion self-psychologists notice
the way in which this thing
inside an inner psychological structure
discernible by anybody that has an eye
to see
called the grandiose self-organization
or variously called the grandiose
exhibitionistic self-organization
that if the personality of the human
self is not able to
to relate to that thing adequately they
will be
mentally ill and we're going to get
into the marks of that shortly but one
of the things that does
is the grandiosity takes the personality
over
in some way that is the infantile
grandiosity
destroys the human being and the great
struggle of the human personality
according to that school
is to learn to function in spite of the
reality
of this potential enemy within
now now in terms of union thought it's
very interesting
this grandiose self-organization is not
necessarily an enemy
it's only an enemy if you don't relate
to it
correctly which gets us
to you see if you
if you if you study this stuff then you
understand why human beings have so much
trouble
now if you're one of these nice
pollyanna's humanistic psychologists to
think
there's nothing bad in there everything
in there
is friendly
but i want you to know that the greatest
of the deaf psychologists in the
psychoanalytic theorist not just unions
know that everything in there is not
friendly
there are some things in there if you
don't learn how to deal with it will
kill you
and we'll do it fast as fast as possible
and so if you're trying to figure out
why you get in so much mischief
you got help
and and in terms of uh of our
of our work here what i would want to
argue is that you got to understand that
it's not all your ego's fault
that is to say it's your ego's
responsibility nobody else is going to
handle it
for you but but there are forces in the
psyche that are not
your ego that would like to see you dead
okay now jungian classical jungian
theory now i'm not
i want to make clear i'm not one of
these so-called archetypal psychologists
i'm interested in a psychology of the
archetypes
that's different
archetypal psychology that's kind of a
large claim i wouldn't want to be
the author of an archetypal psychology
that's a high claim and that means the
prototypical psychology i'm just doing a
simple
sort of journeyman plain old
down-home ordinary psychology of
archetypes
now orthodox quote unquote jungian
theory
plain old centrist theory says there's
an archetypal self
now this archetypal self is a
psychological entity it is
real it is not a theological construct
it is parallel it parallels in these
theories
the grandiose self organization that the
freudians have now finally discovered
and think they invented
see in other words it glows
with what jung called what
luminosity it thank you people have
studied this stuff
this thing is luminous
it glows with power and this is
power that is greater than human power
it is uh it is the the stuff of rudolph
otto's mysterium tremendous mysterium
phasenods
jung throughout his entire work makes it
very clear the ego
must differentiate from that
the best book that you can read on this
whole process
is edinger's book called ego and
archetype
and in that book he shows how through
the human life cycle
the ego the eye of the person begins
merged with that
but gradually differentiates from it and
in the healthy mature personality
has what edinger calls and i like i like
this formulation then ego
self-access or connection
notice that the ego is not identified
with the archetypal self but is
connected with it
what happens if the ego in an adult
is not appropriately differentiated from
the archetypal self
well infantile grandiosity in space
unions just use the word inflation i
like that
fly i think of a basketball you know you
with your
your little uh air hose and you your
deflated basketball and so you
plug it in and you watch the basketball
you know fill out
well the archetypal self is full of
energy
and it will fill up the little
basketball of your ego
but you got to know when to take the
thing off
right you've seen these pictures in
cartoons of the people they can't get
off of the air hose and they
they start to float well that's that's
the metaphor here in jungian thought
that is
there is energy coming off of that
archetypal self
and you need it you got to have it if
you don't have it you will not be
inflated you will be deflated or
what depressed
right so hubris the hubris of the greeks
the pride of the christian tradition
reed reinhold nebors
nature and destiny of man
occurs when the ego in some way or the
other
begins to be contaminated by archetypal
energies
and not just fulfilled or made whole by
these archetypal energies
now i want to bring in here a concept
that young used that you almost never
hear
and i think it's important for us to get
uh because we've got to distinguish
between the personal shadow
and what i want to talk about as the
archetypal shadow
and the whole this is a lot of this is
murky area now everything we do from now
on in this is going to be murky because
jungian thought is still emerging
and there's not any uh definitive
textbook that we can turn to to clarify
all these things and have the last word
on it so this is going to get murky but
i want to show you
some of the issues that are coming up
now
but one of the central ones is this
distinction between the personal shadow
and the archetypal shadow now that a lot
of people used to think the personal
shadow was evil well it's not evil
most most theorists now don't even talk
about it that way
it may be experienced by the ego as
evil because the ego is one-sided and
incomplete
and so the ego may shun something in the
shadow
but let me tell you something it
probably is in some of your shadows here
that is not at all evil
like a lot of people i work with for
example their sense of their own beauty
with a great number of people their
sense of their own beauty
is in their shadow
and if they receive a compliment they
cannot deal with it at all
they have to completely deflect it
that's because they were taught in their
families that it you shouldn't be too
big for your britches
and uh you know you don't want to get
uppity and so forth and so on
uh but that is in the personal shadow
it's not evil
and if you're ever if the person is ever
going to have self-esteem they're going
to have to integrate that part of their
shadow they're going to have to learn
that it is okay to feel good about
yourself
and it's okay if somebody says boy like
i said to jim the other day
man that's a fantastic beard
you know a person ought to be able to
say yeah it is
wonderful see now but but you know in
our mistaken
problems this is where some of the
christian tradition has got problems on
this
if jim were to say yeah it's a wonderful
beard isn't it they'd say oh that man's
full of pride
see but that's not true see that's where
one of this is one of the problems that
the christian tradition has had that is
to say if you if you
if you shine and enjoy it there's
supposed to be something wrong with that
and that's why a lot of people would
rather identify with satan
see because if i have if i have to be
to be exhibitionistic i'll just be bad
see
that's the way a lot of people feel see
we'll get into that more later
but anyway so the personal shadow is
just what is disowned it is not evil at
all it is something that is appropriate
for the human being to integrate and in
fact there is a moral imperative
in jungian psychology to integrate the
shadow the personal shadow
but what a lot of people do not realize
is that jung spoke of
spirit complexes
and he made it very clear that spirit
complexes exist in the psyche
which carry an enormous load of
luminosity
and cannot indeed must not
attempt to be integrated into the ego
if you try to integrate them into the
ego
the ego will be destroyed
see processed you might say at least
possessed
and very often destroyed in er you know
in uh sort of a terminal psychosis
now you see this kind of thing very very
why in a widespread manner you used to
see it more before antipsychotic
medication
i'm serious i mean we've got medications
now that if somebody comes in
if christ comes into your consulting
room uh
you know you better hurry up if you're
going to see him and talk to him because
by the time the psychiatrist gets to him
and gives him some of this antipsychotic
meds
christ will disappear and all you will
have is a very
very sort of zombie-like nice
manageable mental patient see
uh but uh the like one of my students
recently
went to a retreat uh had a monastery and
with a group of people and
had a wonderful time got in touch with
the archetypal self
and after wonderful prayer and
meditation announced to the other people
in the group
i'm really glad i'm here with you
i am the second coming of christ
and i can help the redemption of your
soul and all you have to do is come to
me for
a spiritual conversation
and uh that lasted a few days till they
got the antipsychotic meds
see but but that is something that used
to happen a lot if you used to work like
i did in uh
in uh southern mental hospitals before
there were these antipsychotic meds
you you met a lot of christ uh and saint
francis's
all sorts of folks you know and and you
can see it with your own eyes you could
see the spirit complex
invading a human ego totally
possessing it and in some cases uh
irreversibly now you see the same type
of thing
in individuals who think they are
possessed by
satan and there are more and more people
today
who are into that fantasy you see one of
see i i do a lot of work now trying to
help people understand the psychology of
satanism as a movement it's a burgeoning
movement in the country today
uh right in river city they're probably
satanists in your town
uh and uh there are various branches of
satanists some more benign than others
some of them are just sort of into
assertiveness training because they've
decided you know that the only way i can
really be assertive i can't be a
christian if i'm going to be assertive
i can't be sexual i'm going to be a
christian so i'm going to be a satanist
satan's on the side of sex
well you see why they have pretty good
evangelism efforts
a lot better than some of our churches i
mean but
but there are forms of satanism which
are extremely dangerous because
they uh what they're doing is they're
getting in touch with the spirit complex
that is the
uh opposite of this christ complex
and it too is a spirit complex and it
too cannot be integrated
and what happens is you get a possession
of the human
and they start acting this thing out
they're into what jungians often call a
negative inflation and they do
things that are very interesting they're
very interesting they're very horrible
but the interesting thing is they tend
to do the same types of things
they tend to uh they tend to do a lot of
animal sacrifice around the country and
there's increasing evidence that
that in a widespread basis they are
doing human sacrifice
and one of the most disturbing aspects
is that one of the
more widely accepted practices that
is occurring is ritual child sexual
abuse
i recently was in a conference in which
the medical doctor
uh who was working on this showed slides
of the bodies of children who had been
used repeatedly in
satanic rituals in the midwest
and it was enough to make your blood
curl
uh but but
not for a minute would i as a young
analyst think that that's a human ego
doing that for those children
you know a healthy human ego that's not
a healthy human ego doing a religious
practice
that is a human ego that is possessed by
one of these spirit complexes that
uh in terms of the history of a lot of
this type of thing one of the things
that
that the identification with archetypal
evil will lead to is uh
total domination power dynamics and
sexual behavior
and that's one you know the the the
total dominance
uh and power moves in sexuality
is always associated with that uh with
that particular form of
the archetypal shadow so in other words
there are the spirit complexes that are
in the psyche
that are not the ego
that are both images of light and
wondrous spiritual
uh you know elevation and
images of great dark
sadistic evil they are
structures in the psyche and uh they
cannot be integrated by the ego neither
the good ones nor the bad ones
and so what what one does is to try to
support the ego in its
this identification with all of these
complexes
and the attempt of the ego to use these
archetypal aspects of the objective
psyche to gain
fuel and guidance and fullness
uh in living but not get
caught in infantile pathological
infantile
grandiosity in any of its forms you
follow that so far
i'm i'm much more interested in having
people connect with their healthy
exhibitionism
to their healthy enthusiasm christians
talk about joy
we talk about it more than we experience
it
but but that's what that's about joy is
an experience of healthy exhibitionism
and knowing that the true god loves it
the image of the true god and jesus is
the dancer
in fact if you look at the archetypal
king throughout world mythology
what does the king do in order it dances
the world into existence
in fact if you see that movie richard
gere of all things is king david i
thought that was wild
but one of the true things was that dan
those dance scenes if you study the
history of kingship you know that they
dance the world into they don't force it
into existence
they don't coerce it into existence they
dance it
into existence shiva in the in the
images of the great king
shiva he's seen as dancing
the world and that
is that is the human birthright seeing
christians at their deepest level
understand that but they've never
actualized it very well they got you
know jesus got too much flack about that
and they decided that was
dangerous business the issue that you've
got to deal with
is the question of
jung's assertion which i totally agree
with
that there are many things in the psyche
including the archetypal self which you
do not integrate
you do not integrate the archetypal self
you try to integrate the archetypal self
and you will be crazy
and to the extent that you are crazy it
is to the extent that you're already
doing it and don't know
it see in other words
if you tend to be an abusive male or
female and tend to lord it over others
you are whether you know it or not
you're acting out the god king or the
god queen
and see human beings are supposed to be
in touch the ego is supposed to be in
touch with the god
king and queen not acting it out
see if you're in touch with the energies
of the god king and god queen then you
will be centered i'll go into all the
things that you tomorrow i'll go into
all the things that happen when you're
in touch with that
deep center of the psyche because
they're directly related to christian
virtues in terms of the
past understanding of christian virtues
but but you must not get into some
unconscious possession because when you
do you become the narcissistic
personality disorder
the narcissistic personality disorder is
someone who is possessed
by this sacral kingship within
and lording it over other people is a
good way to say it
they think they are the lord yes
this may be uh going beyond what you'd
like to discuss but
are you open to the possibility that the
archetypal shadow
though it's inappropriate for an
individual ego to encounter maybe the
problem
of the collective race and that it might
be that its redemption
will occur over a period of time by uh
by
the its encounter with any number of
egos
well
that's very complicated uh is there's no
i'm one i'm one of the group of people
that believes that there is a growing
human consciousness
and that that human consciousness as it
grows on the planet
is not tribal that is tribalism and
thought processes is lessened more and
more and more it's not so totally
engendered
simply in one gender or the other it's
not racial
so there is a sense in which the more
human consciousness
matures that it has the human beings
have
less trouble with possession by the
archetypal self
see so uh i would agree with that part
of it that
but it's a lot more complicated than
that because uh
because there are these
you've got the combat myth that's in the
deep unconscious
that the ego can resolve in its own way
for itself
but it can't resolve for the objective
psyche
see i mean it may be
i don't know what to think about all
this it may be that you human beings are
going to solve
god's problems
but uh i wouldn't recommend for your ego
to try to resolve in your own little
life
the conflicts of the objective psyche
uh to me i've seen too many people
trying to do that
and they're almost all addicts
you know of one kind or the other we'll
get into that a lot more tomorrow
but anyway this whole issue now you see
i want to i want to reiterate now the
psychodynamics
of evil i will argue adamantly
because there is mythological support
for this there is comparative
psychoanalytic support for it from
diverse schools that don't agree on much
anything else
that the mechanism of human
destructiveness
is pathological infantile grandiosity
the little lord fault leroy on his high
chair tyrant
his high chair thrown that is the fuel
or the female version of that
now the question as you rightfully raise
and you need to think about during this
conference because you will have to come
down somewhere eventually on this the
question is
how do you explain that in terms of of
jungian psychology of the self
and the ego well you've seen one version
of that
the necessity for the ego self-access
that is you must not identify with the
archetypal self in any of its forms
because if you identify with it you will
be overloaded your circuit breaker is
going to go
and we will see tomorrow you're going to
start having compulsive behaviors
compulsive behaviors of any kind or a
sign your circuits
are overloaded and your defenses are not
working anymore
and so you're getting into acting out
something that you are not
ah so but in jungian psychology there
are different
approaches to this and the different
ways you would locate or talk about evil
now it seems to me the simplest way to
talk about uh
the the uh psychology of evil and
jungian terms is just to be very clear
that whatever else you say it is
inflation
and whatever else you say it is when the
human ego takes in
attempts to take into itself energies
which are not human
they are too numinous for the human now
remember what i said
i want you to take in all the luminosity
that is appropriate to your humanness
i want you to glow i'd like for you to
shine see
i want you to be creative i want you to
be enthusiastic i want you to be fill up
with yourself i don't want you to be
bored with yourself for life
you know so there's some luminosity that
is that is appropriately human
that's the imago day i think
but but evil will occur clinically
speaking not in terms of some meta
theory but clinically speaking when you
start trying to absorb into your ego
energies that are not
absorbable into your ego
and so that's inflation but now let's
get into this thing well now
what causes this evil that you see in
the psyche this destructiveness is this
the fault of the self
now the jungians are all over the place
on this
and let me just show you some of the
options and you probably can think of
other options that i this is not an
exhaustive list but these are some of
the options
you can say that
with jung that the archetypal self
includes archetypal evil
that you've got christ you look at that
look at that
look at those charts he gives you in the
volume ion
a ion archetypal self you've got
christ and satan as structures of the
self
and so you can say well both good and
evil are in the self and then
uh in some theories jung as john has
pointed out young
kind of identifies that god the godhead
itself contains
good and evil as sort of a parallel to
the archetypal self
sometimes they equate the self in god
some unions talk as if the archetypal
self and god are pretty much the same
thing
uh so uh you you might say that
sometimes
that they might argue that human evil
then may be some of it at least done at
the initiative of the archetypal self
and some of them even say even done at
the initiative of god
now then you get a position something
like jack sanford's
where there is sometimes a kind of a
tendency to
to equate the self in god but he's not
quite he doesn't really finally land
there
the archetypal self is an ex expression
sometimes of god in the psyche but
jack sanford sees an arctic
independence of god
and the self and god are good for jack
sanford
see he doesn't want to go along with the
more traditional union readings and he
says while the ego
while it will be the self can be seen
often
you can read this in evil shadows out of
reality
he'll say that while it will be appeared
to the ego that the self
is the author of evil that what is
happening is something that the ego
doesn't want to integrate that should be
integrated
the self is pushing through through
experiences
for that person to integrate and it will
be experienced as evil
so you may experience your your
exhibitionism is an evil thing and you
may think it's awful but
the self may try to get you to bring it
out
and uh so so it's not to jack the source
of real evil the self doesn't really
offer real evil although jack believes
that there is real radical evil
that is in the psyche that is not the
ego
and then sometimes he will follow conkle
and say that that you know conquer
believe
that the ego why satan
that is that ego the egocentric ego
is the cause of evil and jack is
impressed with that
idea of the egocentrism of the ego
uh the question you got to raise
and i and we got to talk about this in
our discussions well now is that all the
egos doings
in other words is an egocentric ego
egocentric because it chooses to be
or has it been possessed
see i mean how much choice is there
there now that's the arguable
issue psychoanalytically and we'll talk
about that in our discussion
and then they there are persons that
think that the archetypal self is not
god it's clearly not god it is more the
imago dave the imago
of god within and see there are even
fraudians
who are atheists and empirically
scientifically see a god image within
they don't believe in god but they see
this god imago
within and there are some unions that
say well that would be
that would be the the imago day then the
question comes up well
but is the self is the is the self
the image of good alone or is the self
does the self contain with it
not just is the self in other words
merely the archetype of order or does it
contain with it
also the archetype of disorder
within the cell see that that's a
theoretical question
is archetypal disorder what you might
call the shiva principle
is the shiva principle a part of the
archetypal self
or is it simply another structure in the
psyche now that is a that is a technical
argument and you you you don't
there's nobody's going to be able to
tell you
which one is right on that
and so there are a number of ways you
can look at this
uh and you can see that there's a
tendency for example with
uh with jack sanford's point of view you
can see that egocentrism and the ego
there's your there's your grandiosity
the egocentric ego
is inflated and grandiose
i want us to remember though what young
had to say about about dealing with evil
he said uh see the thing he
the thing he got into it with christians
about is an interesting thing he
viewed himself as standing up for the
reality
and agency of evil evil is not passive
for jung
he believed that the provocation
in christianity made evil sound too
impotent and too passive and jung
believed that evil was
powerful and aggressive always
and that every person was subject to it
and his point was
that there were two resources he says
that jung says the human ego standing
alone
cannot defend itself against evil
get that the human ego standing alone
cannot defend itself against evil
it but it has only two ways to deal with
it
it can turn to a trans ego source of
goodness
for assistance and
it can turn to human community
for assistance without community without
human community
and a trans egoic source of goodness and
order
the ego will be overwhelmed by evil
thank you thank you thank you
thank you